>> Mark: HEY, WELCOME BACK,
HERE IS TUCKER.
>> Tucker: IF YOU PAY ANY
ATTENTION TO THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IN
WASHINGTON OVER THE PAST 30
YEARS AND IN PARTICULAR IF YOU
PAY ATTENTION WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE WITH THE ATTACKED TOWER.
IT IS WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT,
HIGHER EARNERS AND DONORS.
THEY CARE ABOUT HELPING AMERICAN
COMPANY SHIPPED THEIR JOBS
OVERSEAS TO FOREIGNERS HERE TO
WORK FOR LOWER WAGES.
THEY CARE ABOUT LAUNCHING WARS
IN FAR-OFF PLACES.
THEY HAVE DONE ALL OF THOSE
THINGS COME IN AS THEY HAVE WITH
HELP OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
THE AMERICAN FAMILY HAS DECAYED.
THE MIDDLE CLASS ALONG WITH IT.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS ALSO
DECAYED AT THE SAME TIME.
IF DEMOCRATIC LEADERS DIDN'T
REPEATEDLY MAKE IT CLEAR HOW
MUCH THEY DESPISE THIS COUNTRY
AND PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN IT, THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WOULD BE DEAD
BY NOW.
BUT THE EXTREMISM OF THEIR
OPPONENTS.
BUT DOES IT HAVE TO BE THIS WAY?
WHAT WOULD IT LOOK LIKE IF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY EMBRACED A NEW
AGENDA -- AGENDA, HELPING
AMERICAN FAMILIES FORM AND THRIV
AMERICAN FAMILIES FORM AND THRIE
AMERICAN FAMILIES FORM AND THRI?
HE THOUGHT OF A LOT ABOUT THIS
QUESTION THE EXECUTIVE EDITOR,
JOHNNY THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
SO REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT HAD
AMERICAN FAMILIES AT ITS CENTER
LOOK LIKE?
>> TUCKER, FOR THE PAST 30
YEARS, AS YOU NOTED THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS PAID A LOT
OF LIP SERVICE TO FAMILIES,
ESPECIALLY AROUND ELECTION TIME
TO WIN VOTES, BUT THEY HAVE DONE
VERY LITTLE SUPPORT THE BEDROCK
INSTITUTION THAT HOLDS OUR
COUNTRY AND OUR ECONOMY
TOGETHER.
AMERICA CANNOT BE GREAT UNLESS
THE INSTITUTION TO SUPPORT US
FROM THE BOTTOM UP ARE STRONG.
THESE INCLUDE CHURCHES, SCHOOLS,
INSTITUTIONS OF CIVIL SOCIETY,
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE
FAMILY.
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE FAMILY
DETERMINES THE COURSE OF WHAT
HAPPENS IN SOMEONE'S LIFE.
IT DETERMINES THE COURSE OF THE
CULTURE AND THE COURSE OF OUR
COUNTRY AND THE FAMILY IN
AMERICA TODAY IS UNDER SIEGE.
CONSERVATIVES HAVE RIGHTLY
POINTED OUT A NUMBER OF AREAS
FOR MANY YEARS LIKE THE
PERNICIOUS INFLUENCE OF
HOLLYWOOD, THE IMPACT OF GROWING
IMPACT OF SILICON VALLEY WITH
THE ADDICTIVE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
MARKETED TO CHILDREN INCLUDING
PORNOGRAPHY.
TODAY, CONSERVATIVES ARE FINALLY
STARTING TO WAKE UP TO ANOTHER
THREAT WHICH IS MALIGNANT,
MARKET FORCES THAT ARE
UNDERMINING OUR FAMILIES.
NOW, THERE ARE MANY OF THEM, ONE
OF THEM I LIKE TO POINT OUT IS
CRONY CAPITALISM HERE THAT CRONY
CAPITALISM AS I DEFINED IT IS
COLLUSION BETWEEN BIG GOVERNMENT
AND BIG BUSINESS AT THE EXPENSE
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT IS PRETTY EASY FOR SOMEONE
LIKE PETE BUTTIGIEG TO GRADUATE
FROM A TOP SCHOOL LIKE HARVARD
AND GET A JOB FOR A MANAGEMENT
CONSULTING FIRM IN WASHINGTON
MAKING POWER POINTS FOR A
FACELESS BUREAUCRACY LIKE THE
POSTAL SERVICE.
OR MAYBE IF YOU ARE LUCKY, YOU
KNOW, DESIGNING POWER POINTS FOR
A FOREIGN DICTATOR OR PUSHING
PILLS FOR BIG PHARMA TO MAKE SIX
FIGURE SALARY.
BUT REALLY WHAT IS GOING ON FOR
JOBS ARE BEING SENT TO THE
HEARTLAND TO PAD THE POCKETS OF
A FEW CONNECTED PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
MIDDLE AMERICA IS NOT GOING TO
TOLERATE THAT ANYMORE.
>> Tucker: SO IS IT MIDDLE
AMERICA THE FIRST TO THE MOST
WOUNDED BY THESE ECONOMIC
CHANGES THAT THE COUNTRY HAS
GONE THROUGH?
REPUBLICAN AREAS MOSTLY OR
RELIABLY REPUBLICAN AND DYING
AND THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
WASHINGTON WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO
BE REPRESENTED AND IT DOESN'T
SEEM TO NOTICE.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> WELL, THEY HAVE DELIBERATELY
IGNORED MIDDLE AMERICA BECAUSE
THEY COUNTED ON THEIR VOTES
UNTIL THIS RECENT ELECTION WIN
WISCONSIN, PENNSYLVANIA,
MICHIGAN FINALLY SPLIT TO THE
REPUBLICANS.
THEY ARE STARTING TO REALIZE,
OH, WOW, THE NEW CONSTITUENCY
PART OF THE BASE IF WE WANT TO
MAINTAIN POWER.
THE TRADE DEALS HAVE DECIMATED
THE ECONOMIES AND THE PLACES.
REPUBLICANS ARE TAKING THEM
SERIOUSLY WHICH IS WHY I'M
ENCOURAGED THAT TRUMPIAN THE
WHITE HOUSE IS PUTTING PAID
FAMILY LEAVE FRONT AND
CENTER AT THE AGENDA FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THEY WILL BE HOSTING A SUMMIT ON
THE TOPIC THIS WEEK.
OTHER MEMBERS IN THE SENATE LIKE
MARCO RUBIO HAVE INTRODUCED
BILLS, BILL CASSIDY AND TALKING
ABOUT, GOOD CAPITALISM.
STARTING TO LOOK HOW
CONSERVATIVES CAN SUPPORT THE
FAMILY FROM THE BOTTOM UP.
THEY WILL NEED TO FIND A WAY TO
DO THIS IF THEY WANT TO BE A
PARTY THAT WINS AT THE BALLOT
BOX.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
AND IT IS BECAUSE OF
INTELLECTUAL LEADERS AND THE
PUBLICATION THAT YOU RUN.